what's going on people the results for
the official my academia popularity poll
have finally been released for 2021 and
in this video we'll be going through the
rankings to see whether each character
deserve their place
in the rankings last year we got some
pretty bizarre results with shindo being
the ninth most popular character in the
series despite not actually appearing in
the manga or anime in 2020 for 2021 i've
got the list of the top 20 characters as
voted for by fans in japan and as we
continue the video i'll be revealing
where they place on this newest poll
okay so the 20th most popular character
in my academia is jiro
um now in terms of what she's done this
year in the manga she didn't really do
too much that i can remember in anime
though she was part of bakugo's team
that absolutely destroyed class 1b i
mean i'm pretty sure that was the
quickest match in the entire joint
training arc didn't even last a full
episode um and yeah i guess that was her
main thing this year and the same thing
can be said for the person in 19th place
which was cerro in the maggie he didn't
really have an individual moment but in
the anime he was part of that amazing
team that just like i said destroyed
class 1b
moving on to 18th place we have a
character who is so underrated by the
fans in japan like i honestly can't
believe how underrated this person is
and that is shigaraki yes the main
villain of the series is somehow in 18th
like i cannot believe he's not even in
the top 10 it's ridiculous
especially after the year he's had we
saw it in the anime he had his awakening
he had
such an important development and then
in the manga you know he killed
america's number one hero he stole her
quirk although you know didn't go to
plan but still he did a bunch of crazy
things and yet he's so underrated it
just doesn't make any sense
i guess the one thing you could say is
that for most of this year technically
speaking shiguraki has not really been
himself i guess you could argue that all
for one has really been in control of
his body for the most part so we haven't
really seen the true shiguraki this year
so that is a fair argument uh but still
he should at least be top ten in my
opinion
now for the second year in a row shindo
is a head of sugaraki like i don't know
how this keeps happening honestly i
don't um it's funny though because last
year like i said in the intro he didn't
actually make an appearance in the anime
or the manga but after his amazing
result in the popularity poll heroku she
did you know shoehorn him into the manga
and he had a fight against muscular
where he got beaten pretty quickly
although
when deku beat muscular he mentioned
something about how muscular was
slightly weaker it was heavily implied
that shindo weakened muscular so that
dekker could just beat him
in 16th place we have derby
and
what did he do this year i'm trying to
remember obviously last year he had the
massive reveal of him being toy taraki
and in the beginning of this year we
found out his backstory actually i'm
pretty sure it was like the first
chapter of the year so um since then he
hasn't really done much he's been in the
background a lot the main focus of the
villains has naturally been on shigaraki
and all for one um but i imagine in 2022
he will get that big fight against
endeavour and shoto so i'm sure next
year he he will likely be higher than uh
higher than 16th place
in 15th place we have kaminari in the
anime he did have that one moment where
during the joint training arc he kind of
like used himself as bait and almost
like sacrificed himself in a way and by
doing that he distracted class 1b and
got all their attention on him so that
shinzo and uh and froppy and the rest of
them could all uh excel so yeah that was
a good moment from him but besides that
this year
not really much else but i guess he's
just a popular character regardless
because he's just you know lovable so it
makes sense why you'd be ranked so
highly
now in 14th we had momo
there was a funny moment with momo this
year that i tweeted about it was um
when class 1a was trying to capture deku
and they were trying to like you know
get him to come back to ua momo created
this like mask to put him to sleep and
obviously that would have taken hours
right because whatever she creates she
has to know how it works so she would
have researched this device she would
have done a lot of preparation and then
she would have made it and then in one
second deku just like flicked his neck
and destroyed the whole thing i thought
that was pretty funny just because he
would have put so much effort into it
and he just literally like i said
flicked his neck and destroyed it um but
who else have we got who's after momo it
is all might all might had an
interesting year for a large part of it
he was following decker around in his
batmobile um and then finally after
years he got that meeting with stain and
another interesting thing about all
might is that after his meeting with
stain it genuinely seemed like he's
ready to be a hero again not not
necessarily like a you know what he was
but it seems like he's actually going to
try and help out during this fight
against all for one and given that in
the past we've gotten out of him you
know wearing a cape and like he's trying
to be hero again i feel like in 2022 he
will
help the kids and even though he's
quirkless he will still be contributing
um to defeating shigeraki
in 12th place we have ochako
now her highlight of the year is
definitely her getting deku back into ua
because as we all know
after they retrieved deku from the
public and brought him back to the
school all of the civilians were just
against the idea of bringing him back
because you know deku is all for one's
target so if they bring deku back then
actually all for one's gonna try and
destroy the school or try and break his
way into the school so it took some
convincing and ochako was the main
person who you know argued with the
civilians and told them why they need to
let deku back in so that was her
standout moment of the year
in 11th place we have endeavour
this year was so funny for endeavour he
was basically going on an apology tour
like
in the beginning of the year he was
apologizing to the public then he
apologized to his family then he
apologized to the students like he just
has a lot to be sorry for and in the
anime obviously he apologized to natsuo
whatever medium you're looking at he was
just apologizing to someone
in 10th place is shinzo who had a huge
year when it came to the anime he was
featured very heavily in the joint
training arc um he was the only student
to fight in two separate matches
and
you know it was pretty high because it
had been a long time since shinzo
appeared in the anime i mean he hadn't
really had a significant appearance
since season two which was ages ago so a
lot of anime watchers who didn't read
the manga they would have been like just
so happy to see him again and you know i
definitely was
so yeah shinzo in the top ten it works
it makes sense
the character in ninth place was
actually um brody from the world heroes
mission movie um now i have not seen the
movie as of making this video uh yeah i
know i know i should have seen it by now
but in my defense i did buy two tickets
to go see walter's mission i did go to
cinema to see it but i wasn't allowed
him because i brought my brother who was
12 years old or who is 12 years old and
the movie is a 15 i didn't realize that
when i bought the ticket so we weren't
allowed in i mean technically speaking i
could have gone in without him but that
would have just been mean um so haven't
been back to the cinema since then you
guys let me know is rody a good
character i know that he has this little
uh he has this tiny bird that goes with
him and that's his quirk but yeah i
can't really say anything cause i
haven't seen the movie
anyway in eighth place we have president
mike there was only one time i remember
seeing him and that was when they
brought deku back to ua and he was
trying to like calm down a few of the
civilians besides that i don't know if
he really appeared in the manga i don't
even remember besides that time but
obviously in the anime the whole
shirakuma reveal that was intense it was
very well done um and i guess that
explains his position in the top 10.
in seventh place is izawa who literally
i could say the exact same thing
isabella has been out of action for the
entire year and that is because during
the war arc he lost an eye and he lost a
foot so he has a metal foot now and he
has an eye patch
going up to sixth place we have tenure
and his highlight of the year is the
moment when he reached out to deku
grabbed his hand and i felt like that
moment was kind of like hirokoshi
signifying how important either is to
the to the story this moment wasn't the
only time he was a leader as well
because there was of course the other
time when they were searching for deku
in the first place and he was the one
arguing with nezu like we need to go
after him we need to go get deku and
bring him back
transitioning to the top five now we
have hawks in fifth place and you know
similar to darby hawks had a chapter
dedicated to his backstory at the
beginning of the year but since then we
haven't seen that much of him
we did get a few moments here and there
when he was asking questions about
midoriya or and there was that time when
he helped lady nagant as well um so you
know he hasn't been he hasn't been
missing we have seen him here and there
um it's just that his presence hasn't
been as significant as it was when we
were doing the whole you know
infiltration of the meta liberation army
up in fourth place we had kiroshima and
just being real this was not kirishima's
year i mean in the manga he did not have
as a single individual moment that i can
remember and in the anime you know the
joint training arc it was just not good
to him so
does anyone else remember a big
highlight from this year for hiroshima
if you do let me know in the comments
down below but i personally don't
remember him having like a really good
moment going into the top three
if you've been paying attention to these
polls in the last few years you already
know what the what the order of this is
um as it always is it's shoto in third
place
yeah um so
for shoto this year his highlight i
think it came in world heroes mission
now as i said earlier i haven't seen the
movie but i do know a few things that
happened and i did see the trailer shoto
was doing some pretty cool looking
things
in season five two he had the whole
endeavor agency storyline and them going
back to his house for dinner so yeah
shoto had some spotlight this year in
the anime and in the movie and in the
manga he was a bit like pretty much the
rest of class 1a and that they were just
trying to find deku um so yeah you can't
really say much else
the top two decline back ago
it has been that way i'm pretty sure
since the very first poll ever so
i don't think that's going to change no
matter what anyone else does and i think
the order of where they place you know
deku and bakugo i don't think there's
anything that can happen that would
change that order either because in
second place as has happened for the
last million years in a row we have deku
now this year was perhaps his best case
for not coming second place because he
had a whole arc basically to himself i
mean it wasn't that long but it was
still you know significant and in that
storyline deku was just
you know he left ua he was out there
fighting villains from the past you know
he fought muscular he fought um
overhaul i mean he didn't didn't really
fight overhaul but overall was there and
deku just had
a whole
change in his demeanor he became a lot
more ruthless i felt like this whole
storyline
might have been enough to put him in
first because it was just like him out
there in the city doing his thing um and
being essentially acting like the number
one hero and i say that because you know
he was beating villains that i'm sure
endeavor would have struggled to be
muscular i'm sure endeavour would have
struggled to beat lady negan you know it
wouldn't have been easy so deku was
you know he was fulfilling the role that
a number one hero would fulfill just
beating down these powerful villains all
the time um but yeah what do you guys
think do you think deku deserved first
place this year i feel like he
definitely had more of a chance this
year than he did last year but the fans
in japan they just are in love with baka
go when it comes to bakugou his
highlight of the year would definitely
be him apologizing to deku for like the
bullying and the childhood trauma um
that was definitely a long time coming
it was overdue for sure um so it was
good that we got that moment in 2021 in
terms of his other highlights for the
year um i guess as is the case with um
sarah and enduro as well they had the
joint training arc where they blitzed
class 1b
um
what else did he do i mean he was in a
few other arcs as well wasn't he like
the endeavor agency
i'd say though the main thing was the
apology to deku that was just so
significant
but in terms of everything else it was
nothing too crazy um and that's kind of
one of the reasons i felt like this year
deku should have had a good chance to
beat him um but i guess that apology was
uh yeah it was enough it was enough to
get that first place once again
also before i end the video i completely
forgot to mention deku unlocked two
quirks this year he unlocked the smoke
quark from the sixth user and he also
unlocked the fargin quark
from the third user he put them to good
use you know the way he was combining
all of them especially during the fight
with the lady nagant that was pretty
amazing just something i forgot to
mention so i thought i would put it in
at the end
anyway guys if you enjoyed watching this
video then be sure to drop a like and
hit that sub button if you want to see
uh yearly content like this because i do
this once a year now i guess i if you
haven't seen my video that i did last
year then do check it out it's in the
description below and until the next one
peace out